the corona virus pandemic has plunged
one of the world's most valued
commodities to its lowest levels ever
for the first time in history the price
of oil turned negative this week that's
because the world currently has more oil
than it can use closures of businesses
and restrictions on travel meant to slow
the spread of the coronavirus have
slashed global demand for oil and with
storage facilities full there's simply
no way for it all to go so what's the
view from Africa for that we go over to
Nigeria the continents biggest oil
producer ice but Alex aronia he is chief
operating officer at O and o energy
resources he started out by giving me
his assessment of what's going on in the
industry hi Kristine and thanks for
having me show the entire world today is
shocked with what's going on industry
has never seen these numbers or these
complexity of problems we have
confluence of issues that have come
together to create what I will call in
my time the most worrying period the
only consolation we get from this is
that we identified and we know what the
challenges are and we see a future that
sort of sees them either way I think
overall we're certainly optimistic
in the future but at the very present
time we need to adjust do what we have
to do as companies and as governments
either on the positive side or the
cost-cutting side to weather the storm
and hopefully come out on the other side
ready to do business again
so how has your company been impacted
well Wanda specifically has been
impacted in a multitude of ways first
and foremost as chief operating officer
I do have an operator
that came into the year with a specific
budget immediately we as we saw the
price of oil sort of taker
take a downward trajectory we revised
those budgets and looked to reduce our
cost significantly the capex on the
opposite side and what we've seen in
recent times is perhaps the opportunity
to even do more our prices going as low
as $20 $19 and brent and as you as you
were WTI trading for negative 30 30 plus
dollars we're in a new environment no
government no company could prepare for
this at zero oil price there is no
business there's no commercial case for
us Phoenix in existence so we look
forward and and that's and that's what
we do what kind of support do companies
like yours need bearing in mind that the
oil industry is the lifeblood of the
Nigerian economy the support we need sit
around just managing those issues of
cost and and of course these sessions to
allow us continue business so we can
come out on the other side of this and
and the government is aware of this when
consultations and conversations
currently to deal with the concessions
and other things to palliatives to deal
with how we are able to stay alive
through this you know depress pricing
regime however the government is
committed to a significant amount of
cuts across the joint ventures and the
oil operating
licenses within the country and we've
seen those come through already in some
cases almost 50% budget cuts across the
government has also looked into creating
activity and encouraging the players
within the sector to to create value in
this time embarking on a marginal field
round the the government is looking at
ways in which it can pull that process
together and certainly have these fields
available for for bidders you know it is
indeed the right time to invest in order
at the pressed prices it is certainly
the right time to go in and as prices
creep back up you can gain the benefit
of that how long had your company
survived and the current levels of slump
in demand for oil the current oil price
is certainly are not conducive for
business at a zero price it begs a
question what is a commercial endeavor
gain pursued an entire sector so I can I
can I can confirm that businesses
certainly can't survive you know a
desolate but we see it differently we
see a pandemic that needs to be
addressed first and foremost from a
social distancing and acceleration and
testing perspective to create an interim
defense whilst we find the real defense
which would be a vaccine
to allow business activity and economic
activity continue and sort of rise to
the levels pre the covert pandemic and
then we see the other side which is the
supply considerations across the OPEC
suppliers who contribute about 49% to
the global supply and about 75% to the
total global reserves as well as the
non-opec contributors and to ensure that
there is a favorable market price - and
to drive a business endeavor within this
sector we believe you know 2021 2022
there will be a correction in the
markets and by 2023 we might get up to
full business activity as we ask us as
we knew prior to this pandemic remember
behaviors will change which is the the
ultimate basis for the reduction in
activity it might take a while before
you see large crowds gather it might
take a while globally before you see
people change a habit and flying so
taking all this into consideration 2020
to potentially kill 123 is when I
estimate we would see the world get back
into operational and activity highs of
precoded happened we would have ramped
up in efforts to diversify the Nigerian
economy which is an effect winning the
economy off its dependence on oil leave
the oil sector we see a future that has
an energy mix that energy mix is less
about extracting oil completely from its
constitution and more about increasing
the
contribution of renewables to that
energy mix so you might have less oil
and gas utilization and a bit more
renewables utilization and that's where
we see ourselves the world large is
still configured to consume while large
vessels air transport you know
large-scale manufacturing and I think
this is here to stay for a while even
though we see that progression into
renewables and we encourage and that
actively pursuing investments in that in
that direction